The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today
we start a-- we're
going to take a little break
from parametrized complexity
and talk about something called
exponential time hypothesis,
which I've mentioned a few
times but we haven't really
talked about its many
cool consequences.
I'll abbreviate it ETH.
And the idea is
think about 3SAT.
and the claim is it has no 2
the little of n time algorithm.
So of course you could
make analogous assumptions
about KSAT set for various K.
But in general, the hypothesis
is that for any fixed K, there
is no 2 to the little l of n
time algorithm.
So 3SAT is the smallest
one where that should hold.
2SAT, of course, is easy.
This is not the
maximization version.
And our evidence
for this is merely
that we haven't been able
to find such an algorithm.
There are better than
2 to the n algorithms.
The obvious algorithm
is 2 to the n,
try all possible
assignments times n.
But we won't worry about
the non-exponential part.
The best algorithm to
date is 1.31 to the n.
That's just from
three years ago.
So it's an active
area of research.
Many people have tried to
find better SAT algorithms.
But conjecture is
you cannot get, like,
2 the square root of n, the sum,
and be complete problems have 2
to the square root of
n time algorithms--
we'll see some today.
I'll mention some.
But seems like 2 to
some constant times
n or some constant to
the n power equivalently
is the right answer for 3SAT.
Now one issue to talk
about very briefly--
it won't actually
matter-- is what is n?
Normally n is the
entire problem size,
which would be the
number of clauses,
essentially, because each
clause has three variables.
But the usual
assumption is to say
this is the number of variables
and m is the number of clauses.
But these turn out
to be the same thing.
So one assumption is equivalent
to the other assumption,
so henceforth we don't
need to worry about this.
In general, m is
at most n cubed,
because each clause can have
three different variables,
so there's only n
cubed possible clauses.
But when we're worried
about this little o thing,
we actually care
about polynomials,
because we're in the exponent.
So it turns out you can
sort of think of m and n
as being linearly related--
that's OK-- by something called
sparsification lemma.
It says that if you have a
formula with a superlinear
number of clauses,
you can convert it
into some vaguely reasonable
number of formulas
with a linear number of clauses.
It's, like, 2 to the epsilon
n different formulas,
each with a linear
number of clauses.
And so the end effect
we need to know
is that these two
are equivalent.
We can think of situations
where clauses and variables
are linearly related.
So that's the hypothesis.
Of course, we don't
know how to prove it.
If we proved it, it would
imply p does not equal np.
This is sort of a
strong form of p
does not equal np from
the SAT perspective.
Because we have so many
reductions from SAT,
you can turn this lower bound.
If you assume this
lower bound about SAT,
you can prove
corresponding lower bounds
about other problems we've seen.
While I'm here, let
me just tell you
another version of ETH
called strong ETH, which
is that CNF SAT has no 2 minus
epsilon to the n algorithm.
So the idea is
there's some ideal
constant to the n for each KSAT.
But as K goes to infinity,
that constant goes to 2.
So if you have
really large clauses,
you can't be 2 to
the n, roughly.
This is for all
epsilon greater than 0.
So I won't talk about anything
that needs this assumption,
but there is some work on-- you
can get very specific bounds
on what the constant should
be if you assume strong ETH.
Let's take a review
of past reductions.
And I'm going to start with
3-coloring a graph for here.
So this was our proof
that 3-coloring was hard.
There was a clause
gadget, variable gadget,
this thing of constant size.
And the point is, if I
start with some 3SAT--
this is a reduction from
3SAT-- if I start with a 3SAT
instance that has n
variables and m causes,
the number of vertices
and edges over here
will be some constant
times n plus m.
So 3-coloring, we get order
n plus m vertices and edges.
So what does that give me
in terms of a lower bound?
Well, if I assume ETH that
there's no 2 to the little of n
and no 2 to the little of
m time algorithm for 3SAT,
then I get a corresponding
thing that there's
no 2 to the little of n
time algorithm for graphs
with number of vertices and
number of edges linear in n.
So I state it this way
because for graphs again,
there's the issue of
sparse versus dense graphs.
I could just say
for sparse graphs
here, which each have a
linear number of edges.
So this is, I should
say, ETH implies this.
So while I thoroughly
believe p does not equal np,
p does not equal np, ETH is
a little bit more unknown.
So I'm going to
explicitly mention
ETH teach every time I use it.
And more generally if we look
at various past reductions,
all we need to measure is
something called size blowup.
Remember an np
reduction Karp style,
you start with some instance x,
you make an instance x prime.
And the size of x prime--
this was our reduction
f-- the size of x prime should
be polynomial in the size of x.
What's that polynomial?
That's your blowup.
So if we have n, which is
the size of x over here
and n prime, which is
the size of x prime,
this was polynomial in n
and that is the size blowup.
And so in particular, if
we have linear blowup,
like in this example
of 3-coloring,
then we preserve
the ETH statement.
No 2 to the little o
of n time algorithm,
meaning if there was no 2 to
the little o of n algorithm
for problem A, then
there'll be no 2
to the little o of n
algorithm for problem B,
because you could just convert
to only get a linear size
blowup, run that
algorithm if there was a 2
to the little o of n algorithm.
And then that solves A in 2
to the little o of n time.
So the usual argument,
but now we're
giving explicit bounds
on the running time.
More generally, if you
don't have linear blowup,
let's call this function b of n.
Let's say size of x prime is
always at most some function
b of n, b for blowup.
Then if there's no 2 to the
little o of n algorithm for A,
then there will be no
2 to the little o of b
inverse of n algorithm for B.
So for example, if you have
quadratic blowup, b of n
is n squared, then you
will say that there's no 2
to the square root of
n, no 2 to the little o
of square root of n algorithm.
You can imagine how that goes.
So here are some nice examples
of reductions we've seen.
This one was from lecture seven.
Then from lecture 10, we had
dominating set-- oh, sorry.
I have one more
before dominating set.
This was in the
context of proving
planar vertex cover was hard.
First, planar 3SAT was hard
and then a reduction from 3SAT.
But ignore the planar
issue, because things
are going to be a little
different for planar graphs.
But for general graphs, this
was a reduction from 3SAT.
And there was a constant
number of vertices and edges
for each clause.
And then also here, we had
to make a copy of variable
for each occurrence,
but the total number
of recurrences of all
variables is linear,
because there's only three
occurrences per clause.
So the total number of vertices
in these variable gadgets
is also linear, so the
whole thing is linear.
Size blowup is linear.
And so vertex cover is another
example of this type of result.
Assuming ETH, there is
no 2 to the little o
of an algorithm for graphs whose
number vertices and edges is
order m.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
name for that class?
PROFESSOR: That
should have a class,
but-- I can make
one up, if you want.
We could call it an
ETH-style graph problem,
say sparse graphs no 2 to the
little o of n assuming ETH.
So it's sort of saying it's
linearly related to SAT,
but as far as I know it
doesn't have a proper name.
It should, because
I had to write it
many times in my notes.
Another one was dominating set.
I don't have a slide for
this, because there never
was one, because the
reduction was so simple.
It was if you have an edge
in the vertex cover instance,
you convert it into a subdivided
edge and the original edge
for dominating set.
And then you have
the same problem.
It's the domination.
So it's the same
thing as vertex cover.
You never want to put this
thing in the dominating set.
You might as well move
to one of the neighbors.
So that's again, a
linear size blowup.
And so dominating set
is also in this class,
who shall remain nameless.
And another one
is Hamiltonicity.
We saw a couple of
different proofs.
This one is from lecture seven.
This was ostensibly
for directed,
thought it also claims to
work for undirected graphs.
Linear?
Maybe I'll jump to the
next one, because it's
a bit of a stronger result.
This was maximum degree
3, Hamiltonicity directed.
This was lecture eight.
It's also linear.
I mean, the main
diagram is this.
It's linear if you're not
aiming for planar graphs.
And then there's no
crossover gadget here.
And so the total complexity
of all these things is linear.
So that's cool.
So Hamiltonicity
is another example
of a graph problem with no 2
to the little o of n algorithm,
assuming ETH.
And from this proof-- this was
for directed max degree 3--
and it was also bipartite.
And then we reduced that
to undirected-- sorry.
We reduced from planar
directed max degree 3
to planar bipartite
undirected max degree 3.
And that's of
course also linear.
So all these things
we get for free.
We did them in
different contexts.
That was for planar graphs.
This one was for APX
hardness for independent set.
But we use the same proof.
And we have this biclique
for the variable.
Now here you start to worry
this could be quadratic blowup.
But this was actually a
reduction from 3SAT-3.
So that we didn't have a
very large clique there.
It was actually only
three nodes in it,
so it's more like two edges.
But in general,
3SAT, any constant
would suffice for that proof.
You also have to check that this
reduction from 3SAT to 3SAT-3
is OK.
But it's, again, linear blowup
because the total number
of occurrences of all
variables is linear.
So that was a whole bunch of
free results-- independent set,
3SAT-3.
That's not a graph problem, so
I won't write it in this list.
Now, normally independent set
is the same thing as clique.
In this universe,
that's not quite right
because we're talking
about sparse graphs.
For clique, it's still
the case that there's
no 2 to the little o of
number of vertices algorithm.
But the number of edges used to
be linear for independent set
and becomes
quadratic for clique.
So you have to be a little
careful with clique.
So all is good as
long as we're talking
about non-planar graphs.
What about planar graphs?
Well, this is not true
for planar graphs.
In general, you tend to get
2 to the square root of n
algorithms, and that's
tight, assuming ETH.
So for example, planar 3SAT
we had a crossover gadget.
And in the worst case,
there are a quadratic number
of crossings.
And so the blowup
in our problem size,
because we spend
some constant number
of vertices per crossover,
the blowup is quadratic.
And so for, say,
planar 3SAT, ETH
implies no 2 to the little o
of n or 2 to the little o of m
algorithm-- sorry,
with square root.
So with 3SAT, it's
a little annoying
because we have to think
about variables and clauses
separately.
So the size blowup is not
quite as uniquely defined.
But just analyzing number of
variables, number of clauses
separately, the blowup
is quadratic in both.
So that's the
lower bound we get.
And then I have planar
3-coloring, vertex cover,
dominating set, Hamiltonicity,
independent set.
All of them have the
property that ETH implies.
No 2 to the little o of
square root of n algorithm
for planar graphs.
Now planar graphs
are always sparse,
so I don't need to worry about
how many edges versus vertices.
n is within a constant of both.
How you prove that?
Exactly the same proofs
that we just looked at.
They were all actually proofs
for the planar problem,
but they all had some
kind of crossover.
Either they started from
planar 3SAT, in which case
they were already quadratic.
Like this one was
from planar 3SAT
and it was a linear
blowup from that.
So it's only quadratic overall.
This one was again, from planar
3SAT and linear after that.
This one was from 3SAT.
And then there was a
custom crossover gadget,
which I don't have
the slide for here.
But for each of
these crossovers,
we paid something, so we
get quadratic from 3SAT.
And that's linear, of course.
And this is not a planar
independent set reduction,
so I don't have one here.
You have to fill in your own.
And one other one was coloring.
We did the planar
3-coloring gadget.
Again, you pay constant
for each crossing.
So quadratic reduction
from 3SAT-- all of them
end up being quadratic overall.
Independent set's the only
one I haven't shown you.
And-- cool.
So this is a sense in which
even though the planar problems
are np hard, they a
little bit easier.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that was [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I think-- I
should double check.
I'm pretty sure all
of these problems
have 2 to the square root
of n time algorithms.
I'm confident enough that
I will write it down.
I think the general approach
is Lipton Tarjan separator.
But that's about the level
of detail I remember.
Oh, yeah-- also,
all planar graphs
have tree width order
square root of n.
And generally, that will
give you such an algorithm.
So that was-- question?
AUDIENCE: Are there
any of these problems
that you can, in a sense,
preserve the difficulty
in a planar graph?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a good question.
We might get to some.
I'm about to shift gears
into parametrized complexity.
And in that setting-- I
would say generally no.
But there are certainly
some exceptions
where you can encode
a non-planar problem
into a planar structure.
But most natural problems
tend to be like this.
But there definitely
are examples.
We might even see one.
This is sort of-- this could
have been in lecture two,
and maybe it should have been.
But ETH is nice
because it gives you
a bit more of a
quantitative sense
of how much running time
you should expect out
of your algorithms.
It gives you
motivation for going
for linear blowup when
possible, or at least
minimizing your blowup and lets
you distinguish between planar
and non-planar problems.
But we're in the middle of
parametrized complexity.
And I mentioned all
this in particular
because it has an
even bigger impact
on parametrized complexity.
So let's shift
over to that world.
Now first of all, we get two
sort of trivial consequences
just from these statements.
They're trivial,
but in some cases
they're actually interesting.
So they're easy to prove, but
actually give tight answers
for a few problems.
So for the natural
parametrizations,
a vertex cover is a vertex
cover size at most k.
Longest path, which
is the optimization
version of Hamiltonicity,
is their path--
in the parametrized
version, is their path
of length at least k?
Dominating set of size k,
independent set of size k
upper bound and lower bound.
In particular, there can't be
a 2 to the little of k times
polynomial in n algorithm,
because there's no 2
to the little o of n algorithm.
This is assuming ETH.
Because in particular,
kb could be n.
Now this is not exactly
what we care about.
What we care about is whether
there's an f of k times
polynomial in n algorithm.
But this at least gives
you a lower bound on the f.
So in particular, for dominating
set and independent set,
this is not a very
interesting result,
because in fact we will
show, assuming ETH,
these do not have FPT
algorithms at all.
There's nothing of that form.
But for vertex cover,
it's interesting
because that is FPT.
And there is a constant to
the k times polynomial n in n
algorithm.
We saw a 2 to the n
times n algorithm.
And this shows
that that's tight.
So there's no better-- it
gives you a bound on f.
For vertex cover, c to
the k is the right answer
for some constant c.
And if you assume
strong ETH, you
can actually figure out what
the-- well, you could try
to prove with the constant is.
We don't know the right
answer for vertex cover.
Some of these problems, we do.
Longest path, same deal.
It's FPT, so it's easy
to find short paths.
And the algorithm is
like 2 to the order k
times polynomial in n.
And similarly for planar
problems, if we have ETH,
there's no 2 to the little
o of square root of k times
polynomial n for those same
problems on planar graphs.
For clique, actually
this should also work.
Clique is OK because
k is the number
of vertices in the clique.
And so even though the
number of edges is quadratic,
this would still hold.
For a planar clique, of
course it's polynomial.
So I can't put clique down here.
The maximum clique
size is 4, so there's
an n to the 4 algorithm.
Again, this is interesting
because for dominating
set, independent set, vertex
cover and longest path,
there are 2 to the square root
of k times polynomial in n
algorithms.
So this is actually
a tightness result.
There exists 2 to the order
square root of k n to the order
1 algorithms for planar
graphs for those problems.
This is called subexponential
fixed parameter tractability.
And there were a bunch of those
results in the early 2000s.
And then a theory called
bidimensionality kind
of characterizes when it's
possible, or gives you
a big set of examples
where it is possible.
But that's algorithm, so
we're not covering it.
So all well and good.
So for planar or dominating
set, that's interesting.
But for general
dominating set, we
know dominating
set is w2 complete,
we think that means
there's FPT algorithm.
Independent set in
clique, our w1 complete,
we also think that
means no FPT algorithm.
Assuming ETH, we can
actually prove that.
So let's say there's
no FPT algorithm
for clique/independent
set assuming ETH.
So that's a theorem
we will prove.
If you believe in ETH,
then w1-- these problems
are complete for w1--
w1 does not equal FPT.
These are the FPT problems.
And in fact, we can prove
a much stronger bound.
Very non-FPT-- these
algorithms generally
have an n to the order k
algorithm, or if they're in xp,
then they have some n to the
k to some constant algorithm.
But we can't even
reduce that exponent
below k for any-- for clique
and independent set, let's say.
And if you reduce clique
and independent set
to some other problem,
you can, just like we've
been doing over
here, you can keep
track of the parameter blowup.
And if it's a quadratic
blowup, then you'd
get that there's no n to the
square root of k algorithm.
We'll actually do that in
a moment for planar graph
problems.
But for general graphs,
clique and independent set,
no f of k for any
computable function f times
n to the little of k algorithm.
So this is much stronger
than FPT does not equal w1.
And this is a result from 2006,
so fairly recent by Chen et al.
So let's prove it.
It is essentially a
reduction from 3-coloring.
But it's unlike
most reductions we
think about,
because-- well, it's
unlike parametrized reductions.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, so is this
[INAUDIBLE] from claiming
that the xp hard these problems?
PROFESSOR: Yeah. xp hard
is really way up there.
None of the problems
we've talked about
are xp hard, unless something
happens with p versus np.
AUDIENCE: But xp [INAUDIBLE]
problems that you have--
PROFESSOR: These are
in xp, but they're also
in-- these problems
are actually in w1,
which is much smaller than xp.
Yeah, I mentioned xp because of
the n to the k to some constant
is related in the same vicinity.
But it's not directly about xp.
So normally when we do
parametrized reductions,
we start from a
parametrized problem
and we reduce to a
parametrized problem.
Here, we are reducing from
an unparametrized problem.
3-coloring has no parameter.
And we are going to
reduce to clique,
which has a parameter, namely
the size of the clique.
So it's a little
weird, but you've
got to get started somehow.
So we're going to
introduce a quantity k
and set it how we want to.
So here's the idea.
We are given an
instance of 3-coloring.
We're given a graph.
We're going to split the
vertices into k groups, each
of n over k vertices.
And remember, we know
that 3-coloring has no 2
to the little of
n time algorithm.
That's what I just
erased, assuming ETH.
So I'm going to choose
k in a little bit.
But let me first tell
you the reduction.
So we're going to
create a new graph.
Let's call it g prime, with
k groups of not n over k,
but 3 to the n over k vertices.
Why 3?
Because we are going to think
about all possible 3-colorings
of those n over k vertices.
So it's corresponding.
For every group up here,
we're going to just write down
every possible 3-coloring.
So obviously, n over k
has to be quite small,
every possible 3-coloring of
those and n over k vertices.
So the intent is that
in our clique problem,
that we want to choose
exactly one vertex from each
of these groups.
So k is supposed to be
the size of our clique.
That's why I wrote it this way.
So at the moment, I have
vertices but I have no edges.
Each of the groups is going
to be an independent set,
so that means you can
only choose at most one
vertex from each group,
to make a clique.
And we are going to
connect to colorings
if they're compatible.
by an edge nG prime
if compatible.
So the idea is, here is
one group, size n over k.
Here is another group
of size n over k.
And if you color these
vertices some colors--
I'm only using one color--
and you color some colors over
here, now it's coloring
within the group,
but there are some
cross edges between here
which may be incorrect.
They may be monochromatic.
And so we check
whether the coloring
of this and the
coloring of this is
consistent with all the cross
edges between those two groups.
If it is compatible, if it's a
valid coloring of both groups,
we connect them by an edge.
This coloring corresponds
to single vertex in G prime
and this coloring corresponds
to a single vertex in G prime.
And we add an edge if it's OK.
We don't add the
edge it's not OK.
And if we're looking
for a clique,
that means we need to choose a
coloring for each of the groups
where everything is
pairwise compatible.
And that represents
all the edges.
Every edge is either within
a group, in which case
it was taken care
of at this stage.
I guess I should say is at
most, 3 to the n over k.
I only want valid 3-colorings.
Or the edge crosses
between two groups
and then it will be
considered when we think about
whether there's an edge.
In a clique, there
are pairwise edges
and so everything is
pairwise compatible.
So never mind the claim.
You should be convinced this
is a valid reduction, in terms
of a correctness standpoint,
from 3-coloring to k
clique for any k.
The construction depends on k.
So what do we set k to?
Here is a setting
for k that will work.
I don't have a ton of
intuition for this, other
than the algebra works.
Essentially, we need
to set it just--
we want to set k to, like, a
tiny, super-constant thing.
So just a little bit,
little omega of one.
And I need to give that
little of k a name.
So I'm going to say, let's
say k clique could be solved
in f of k times n to the k
over s of k time, where s of k
is some monotone, increasing,
and unbounded function.
I need that s goes to infinity.
That's the meaning
of little of k
is that you can
divide by something.
And you can assume
without loss of generality
that the something is
monotone increasing,
but in particular it
should go to infinity
as k goes to infinity.
It might go there very slowly.
It could be, like, 1 over
2 to the k or something.
But something little--
s is little omega of 1.
But now I have this quantity s.
And I'm going to set k as large
as possible so that f of k
is at most n and k to the
k over s of k is at most n.
My goal here is to
make k a function of n.
And so one choice of k is
basically f inverse of n.
So f, remember, was the
dependence on k, so here.
This will turn out to work.
So you can think of k
just being f inverse of n.
But there's actually
another constraint.
It's another inverse thing.
I want k to be at most, the
inverse of this relation.
So I'm basically taking the
min of these two functions of n
that will be a function
of n, which is growing.
I mean, you can check.
If you set k to be a constant,
of course this is true.
So you can set it a
little bit superconstant
by inverting this relation.
That gives you some value of
k that would satisfy this,
some function k equals k of
n that would satisfy this.
And I want to take
the min of those two.
Still a growing function of n.
We'll need that in a moment.
And I get these
two inequalities.
Now it is just a computation of
how much running time I have.
So I want to plug
this algorithm-- this
was an algorithm for k clique.
I have this instance
of k clique, which
looks a little weird
because it's got
potentially a lot of vertices.
I'm just going to plug that in.
This is my n prime, the new--
well, the number of vertices
is this times k, because
they're k groups.
So a number of vertices
in G prime is k times 3
to n over k at most.
So we just plug that
into this running time.
And we get f of k times that
number of vertices, k times 3
n over k at most.
So less than or equal to
the power k over s of k.
And now we do some manipulation.
We know that f of
k is at most n.
That will be enough
for this term.
This is at most n times-- I'm
going to split this apart.
So we have k to the
k over s of k power.
And then separately, we
have 3 to the n over k
to the k over s of k.
Again, k to the k
over s of k, that's
something I get to assume
is less than or equal to n.
So this is less than
or equal to n squared.
And then the k's cancel.
And we're left with 3
to the n over s of k.
I'm going to remind you
k is a function of n
that is unbounded and
monotone increasing.
So this is 3 to the little
o of n, also known as 2
to the little o of n.
So I just needed to choose k
to be slightly superconstant.
And I wanted to get rid of these
terms, so I made them at most n
and took those
inverses, took them in.
And boom, we get
a contradiction.
This contradicts ETH.
This implies ETH is false.
So if you assume ETH, running
backwards you get that k clique
cannot be solved in
such a running time.
And so we get this very
strong lower bound.
There's no f of k
times n to the little o
of k algorithm for k clique.
So in particular, k clique is
not fixed parameter tractable.
I think that's pretty neat.
And henceforth, you care
about parameter blowup.
I mentioned it
briefly last class.
But in general, you map some
problem x with parameter k
into a new instance x prime
with parameter k prime.
And k prime just has to be
bounded by any function,
any computable function of k.
But if it's a linear function,
you preserve this strong bound.
If it's quadratic function, then
you get there's no f of k times
n to the little o
of square root of k.
If it's an exponential function,
which is fair game here,
you get a weaker bound.
You still get that
there's no FPT algorithm.
But you don't get a nice--
not a very impressive bound
in terms of n on the right.
AUDIENCE: Is there a name
for this type of reduction?
PROFESSOR: I don't have one.
There's only one
that I know of, so I
don't think I will try
to come up with a name.
Once you have this,
you can-- last
class we reduced k clique
to all sorts of things.
And so we get a
lot of-- for now,
you just reduce from
clique or variations.
And so you get
lots of good stuff.
What do you get?
Last time we covered a
reduction from clique
to multicolored clique
and independent set.
And if you look at that
proof, k prime equals k.
We had a quadratic blowup
in the problem size,
but the parameter
didn't change at all.
So this is good news.
That means this problem,
or these two problems,
has no-- assuming ETH,
there's no f of k times
n to the little
o of k algorithm.
And also, we covered a
reduction to dominating set.
Even though dominating
set was w2 hard,
we still reduced from
multicolored clique
to dominating set.
And then from dominates set,
we could reduce to set cover.
All of these reductions
preserve k exactly.
All we need is that they
preserve it linearly.
But then we get
this kind of result
for all of those problems.
We covered a reduction
for partial vertex cover.
But I think the reduction
we covered was not linear.
But there is one.
So I'll just state
this as a result,
but this is another one
where we covered a reduction,
but it wasn't the
most efficient one.
I think we lost a
quadratic amount.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we happen
to know if FPT and w1 are
separated assuming
only [INAUDIBLE]
and not assuming ETH?
PROFESSOR: We do not know that.
The best classical
assumption is ETH
implies w1 does not equal FPT.
I also don't know offhand
whether FPT does not equal
w1 implies p does not equal NP.
I think there's this
result along those lines,
but I'm not sure if
that's literally true.
So intuitively it's stronger,
but-- other questions?
AUDIENCE: So this is
strictly better lower bound
than those over there?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Good question.
So before we switched
to parametrized land,
we said-- like over here,
we had there was no 2
to the little of n algorithm.
Here we're getting that
there's no f of k times
n to the little of k algorithm.
I think that is stronger
than the old bound.
Though I guess you have to think
about it problem by problem.
It depends on how k could
relate to n in general.
I think for these
problems though, it
is a stronger result.
Because k is at most n.
And k can be close to n.
So the next topic-- just
taking a little breather.
This is all good for
non-planar graphs.
For planar graphs, we actually
haven't seen any w1 hardness
results yet.
And that's because a lot
of planar problems are FPT.
There are, in fact, 2 to
the square root of k times
polynomial in n algorithms for
a ton of planar graph problems.
But there are some that are
hard, some that are w1 hard.
And as you might expect, this
k becomes the square root of k
because we get a quadratic
blowup, for some problems--
not quite all of them.
So this comes back
to Jason's question.
And maybe I'll go up here.
Let me briefly
mention in general
if k prime of x prime is at
most some g of k of x, this
was part of our--
in the definition
of parametrized reduction,
then if there's no f of k n
to the little of k
algorithm for problem A,
then there is no f
prime of k prime times n
to the little o of g inverse
of k prime algorithm for B.
So I think the
analogous statement
was up here for size blowup
and regular np reductions.
But for parametrized reductions,
I mean, the dependence on k
is just an arbitrary
computable function.
So that doesn't change.
But the exponent
changes correspondingly.
So if you square k, we get the
square root in the exponent.
So let's do some
planar problems.
I'm pretty sure all
of the w1 hardness
results for planar problems
are within the last five years.
So it's a pretty
recent direction.
And the key insight is a
problem called grid tiling,
which I have a slide for.
So this is a problem invented
by Daniel Marx in 2007.
And so the input looks like this
and the output looks like that.
So in general, you're given
a k by k matrix of sets.
Each set has some number
of 2D coordinates.
These coordinates
range between 1 and n.
So it's k by k, small
matrix, but each cell
has a ton of stuff in it,
up to n squared pairs.
And your goal is
to-- in this example,
all the numbers are
between 1 and 5.
So n equals 5.
And it's 3 by 3, so k equals 3.
Your goal is to choose
exactly one element
from these sets, such that
if you look in any column
the first coordinates
are all the same.
Here, the first
coordinate are all 1.
Here, first
coordinates are all 2.
And in any row, the second
coordinate is the same.
Here they're all 4.
Here they're all 2.
Here they're all 3.
So that's a valid solution.
As you might expect,
this is np complete.
But furthermore, it's w1 heart.
I should say sij--
just gives you
some notation-- is a subset
of 1 up to n squared for all i
and j in 1 up to k.
That's what the
input looks like.
The squared means you
have ordered pairs.
And then your goal is to
choose an xij out of each sij
so that in any row, the first
coordinates match any column.
Sorry.
In any row, the second
coordinates match
and in any column, the
first coordinates match.
So claim is this is w1 hard.
And also now, we know w1
hardness is not the most
we could hope for.
We also want to know what
the parameter blowup is
and how we can relate
it back to ETH.
So here we will
get the same bound.
There's no f of k times n to
the little o of k algorithm,
assuming ETH.
So here we will not
lose a quadratic thing.
But notice that this
thing is k by k.
So, while we've defined
the parameter to be k,
there's kind of a quadratic
amount of stuff going on.
You're selecting k
squared different things
in the solution.
That's still OK.
I mean, k is still the number of
rows or columns of the matrix.
But typically, the
reason this problem
is interesting-- this is, like,
a starting point for planar
graph problems,
because you can replace
each of these
cells of the matrix
with the gadget that
somehow represents
all the things in that set,
but that now these constraints
that all the things
in the column
agree in the first
coordinate, you can
think of as a local constraint.
Because really, you just need
that the guy you select here
has the same first coordinate
as the guy you select here.
You only need to
constrain adjacent cells.
Because if his adjacent
cells are equal,
then the whole
column will be equal.
And if adjacent rows have
equal second coordinates,
then the whole column will
have equal second coordinates.
So as long as you
can build gadgets
that just check with
their neighbors,
that will give you a kind of
planar graph structure, or a 2D
geometry structure if you're
doing a geometric problem
and it lets you work with
things kind of locally.
But when you do that, of course,
typically k becomes k squared.
And that's where you get the
square root of k up here.
But it won't disappear yet.
So how do we prove this?
We're going to reduce from
clique because that is
our favorite w1 hard problem.
And it has this kind of bound.
And so it's going to
be a linear reduction.
In fact, k prime will equal
k and n prime will equal n.
n here is the maximum coordinate
values in the original problem.
n prime is the number of
vertices in the clique.
And I'm going to write
down the reduction
and then show you a picture.
It's hard to actually
draw the full reduction.
It's easier to write it
down generically and then
show you kind of a little
slice of a real example.
It's a little bit
confusing, because there are
four parameters lying around.
There's which cell are you
in, which I'm denoting by ij.
i is which row you're in. j
is which column you're in.
So this is the set of
things at row i column j.
But then separately,
there the coordinates
that are inside the cell.
And here I'm denoting
that by vertices, because
for us, what this says is
that the vertices map 1 to 1
with coordinate values.
But these coordinate values
are different from the ij
coordinate values.
The ij's are always
between 1 and k.
These coordinate values
are between 1 and m.
Probably should have a term
for those, that distinction.
But such as it is, ij
is between 1 and k. v
and w are between 1 and n.
So there's two types of cells.
There's cells on the
diagonal of the matrix
and cells off the diagonal.
This is for i not equal to j.
On the diagonal, you just
have pairs of the form vv.
So that's supposed to
represent the vertex.
And so basically what you
choose on the diagonal
is going to correspond to
the clique that you want.
Because the diagonal has size
k, and so each diagonal item
is going to have
to choose a vertex.
It's going to turn out that
vertex will be in a clique.
Why will it be in a clique?
Because the off
diagonal entries are
going to force that
there are edges
between corresponding vertices.
So the off diagonal
entries will have,
for every edge-- and we're
assuming no loops here--
for every edge, we put vw
an item in the set of pairs.
And if this is an undirected
graph, we'll put vwnwv.
And so in fact, all of the off
diagonal entries look the same,
I guess.
And all of the diagonal
entries look the same
in terms of the s sets.
So let's look at an example.
Suppose you choose this 2-2
diagonal entry to be vertex i.
Didn't assume very much.
But from the constraints
of the grid tiling problem,
we know that the whole row here
has the same second coordinate.
And the whole column here has
the same first coordinate.
So if you choose
the vertex i here,
that forces i to appear
throughout there.
And if you look at some other
vertex, vj on the diagonal,
then same thing happens.
You have j second
coordinate here
and j first coordinate there.
I see there's a slight
typo on these slides.
This should be a j.
That should be an i.
The colors are right, though.
So just look at the colors.
Now, for this to be
in the set, there
must be an edge
between vi and vj.
And this is true for all i and
j; therefore you have a clique.
Now one thing that's important
is that vi is distinct from vj.
Otherwise, you could just put
vi in all the diagonal entries,
and everything is vi vi.
But because we said
v does not equal w
for these sets, the fact that
there is a valid choice here,
the fact that vi vj is a
valid thing in this item
means that vi does not equal vj.
So these are all
distinct vertices.
There's exactly k of them.
And so this problem has
a solution if and only
if there was a k clique
in the original graph.
Clear?
I guess these entries are
technically correct if you
view these as unordered pairs.
Because we're in an undirected
graph, everything is flippable.
So that proves that grid
tiling is as hard as clique.
And it was a linear reduction.
We started with value k.
We ended up with a thing
whose parameter was k.
AUDIENCE: Say
something again like,
it just seems like
you've just redefined
your n and k to be square root
of what you might normally.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so if you prefer,
you could define k to be the
number of cells in the matrix.
And then what you would get
here is there's no f of k n
to the little o of square root
of k algorithm, assuming ETH.
It's just a matter of
what you define k to be.
You're going to either lose
a square here or later.
And I think-- so I'll
show you why in a moment,
why you might
define it this way.
Because here's going to be a
planar graph problem, kind of,
that does not blow up k at all.
Turns out, sometimes
you don't have
to blow up-- this k turns
out to be the correct k.
So let's do that example.
It's called k outer
planar list coloring.
There's two things
I need to define--
list coloring and outer planar.
Let's start with list coloring.
So in list coloring, given a
graph and for every vertex,
you're given a list
of valid colors.
And your goal is
to color the graph.
Again, no edge should
be monochromatic.
And the color you
choose for vertex v
must be on the list Lv.
So this is a generalization
of k coloring.
k coloring is the
case where Lv equals 1
through k for all vertices.
This is, of course,
a harder problem.
And turns out, it's quite hard.
For example, it's NP
hard for planar graphs.
That's not surprising,
because 3-coloring is NP
hard for planar graphs.
And size of Lv is less
than or equal to 3
for all v. The hardness
of planar 3-coloring
gives you that.
So there's also no
natural parameter here,
because you can't parametrize
by number of colors you have,
because even when it's
three, this problem is hard.
So we're going to parametrize
by something else, namely
a quantity called
outer planarity.
If you know what tree width
is, you can think tree width.
But tree width is a
bit messy to define,
so I'll stick to
outer planarity, which
for planar graphs is
within a constant factor.
So outer planarity-- if
you have a planar graph,
this would be an example of
a graph of outer planarity 2.
Let me draw you an example of
a graph of outer planarity 1.
Suppose all of the vertices
are on the outside face
of your planar graph, or all
the vertices are on one face.
Then that's an outer planar
graph, or 1 outer planar graph.
If you have a graph
where there are
vertices on the outside
face, and if you remove
all of those vertices
from the outside face,
the remaining vertices are
all on the outside face,
this is 2 outer planar.
In general, if you have
to remove the vertices
on the outside face
k times before you're
left with no vertices, then
your graph is k outer planar.
And that k is your
outer planarity.
So this is an example of a
problem that's-- there's no
natural parametrization because
it's not an optimization
problem.
So we're going to throw
in a parametrization that
often works out quite well.
Usually if you take
planar graphs parametrized
by outer planarity, they are
fixed parameter retractable.
For example, k
coloring, parametrized
by outer planarity, is FPT.
But list coloring is not.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
the outer planarity
depend on the embedding?
PROFESSOR: It depends only
slightly on the embedding.
I think only by an
additive of 1 or something.
So it won't matter from a
parametrization perspective.
Definitely within
a constant factor.
Good question.
So what we're going to
show is that this problem
parametrized by
outer planarity--
so one note is it is in XP.
There is an n to
the outer planarity
and to the k algorithm using the
bounded tree width algorithms,
which I won't go into.
But we will show that is
w1 hard, and assuming ETH,
there's no f of k n to
the little of k algorithm.
So here's an example of
a planar graph problem
where we do not get square root
of k, which I think would also
answer your earlier question.
And this is the reduction.
It's a reduction
from grid tiling.
So the idea is if you
have a k by k grid,
we're going to make something
like a k by k grid graph.
Now we have to represent
the choice here.
We're given a set of pairs
for each of these grid
cells, which we're now
representing as a vertex.
But conveniently, we have
a choice aspect here.
So this is not-- this a thin
[? veal ?] for grid tiling.
We have this list, Lv, for
each vertex of valid choices
you could make for that vertex.
So we're going to
let L uij-- so this
is reduction from grid tiling.
L sub uij equals sij.
So that's the
choice that happens.
For every vertex, we
have to choose one color.
That mimics the fact that
every grid cell in the matrix,
we have to choose
one item from sij.
So most of our work
is already done.
Now we have to constrain.
If you look at two
adjacent vertices,
if they're adjacent
in a row, then they
must have the same
first coordinate--
I can never remember.
They should have the same
second coordinate, sorry,
if they're in the same row.
And if they're in
the same column,
they should have the
same first coordinate.
So these vertices,
which are called
v for the vertical
connections and h
for the horizontal connections,
are going to achieve that.
And it's a little bit
tedious to write down.
Basically, let's say
between uij and ui plus 1j,
so those two vertically
adjacent vertices,
we're going to add a vertex
vijcd for two colors c and d,
with list of size 2 c,d for all
colors not agreeing on first
coordinate.
Again, this is hard
to draw in the figure,
but easier to write down.
So there's a lot of these
vertices in between two
adjacent ui vertices.
There's going to be a bunch.
They're parametrized
by two colors,cd.
Remember, colors
are pairs of things,
but colors correspond to the
items that are in the sijs.
But don't worry about
that so much here,
except there are colors that
are compatible, that they
have the same first coordinate.
And there are colors
that are incompatible.
For any two incompatible
colors, which is most of them,
the ones that don't agree
on the first coordinate,
we are going to add one of these
vertices whose list is exactly
cd, the two incompatible colors.
What that means is, suppose
this vertex chooses c.
Well, then there's a
vertex here with list cd.
It cannot choose c, because
then that edge would be
monochromatic.
So it must choose d, which means
this vertex cannot choose d.
So overall, what this means
is that these two vertices
must choose a compatible
color, because we rule out
all the incompatible pairs.
So list coloring
you can do a lot,
but in particular
we can simulate grid
coloring-- sorry, grid tiling.
We're not exploiting a ton of
the structure of grid tiling,
but we get a nice result
here and it's tight.
I didn't write down what
you do for the horizontal,
but it's symmetric.
So that's nice.
This is one of the few
planar problems where
you don't get a square root.
The next two, you will
get a square root.
But before I get to
the actual problem,
here's a variation
of grid tiling, which
is a little tricky
to prove hard,
but is just as hard
as grid tiling.
Here we need that in every
row-- here's the input,
here's the output.
Easier to look at the output.
In any row-- sorry,
that's a column.
In any column, the
first coordinate
is monotonically increasing.
Doesn't have to
strictly increase,
but you have a less than
or equal to constraint.
This is less than
or equal to this.
4,4,4.
Here they happen to be equal.
2,3,3.
Here they increase a little
bit, similarly in every row.
2,3,5-- they're
monotonically increasing.
1,2,2, 2,2,3.
So this is a valid solution
to grid tiling with less than
or equal to.
That's how it's called.
I will not prove
that this is w1 hard.
I do have a figure for it.
It turns out to be
a linear expansion.
If you have a k by k grid,
we're going to end up with a 4k
by 4k grid.
That part is important.
So we get the same kind of
hardness result, no f of k
and a little o of k, because we
only expand k by a factor of 4.
And this is a description
of what the sets are.
It's kind of messy,
but it effectively
forces that the
choice on the left
is actually equal to
the choice on the right,
even though it only has the
ability to specify less than
or equal to.
But you-- equal is something
like modulo capital n, where
n is some really large number,
like 10 times little n--
something like that.
The details are kind of messy,
so I will instead-- I mean,
we could just take
this as given.
This is, like, a core
problem to start with.
And you can use it to represent
lots of nice planar graph
problems and 2D problems.
So I have one example of each.
These are all from this
upcoming book on fixed parameter
tractability.
So you saw it here first.
This book will come
out early next year.
So here's a problem.
It's called scattered set.
This is a generalization, in
some sense, of independent set.
So let me define it over here.
I would also naturally
call it d independent set.
It might even be called
that in the literature.
So in this problem,
you're given a graph.
And you're given two numbers,
two natural numbers, k and d.
And you want to find k vertices
with pairwise distances
greater than or equal to k.
Sorry, greater
than or equal to d.
So if d equals 2, this
is independent set.
Independent set
says the distance
between any pair of chosen
vertices should be at least 2.
There's no adjacent
ones of distance 1.
d equals 1 is not interesting.
d equals 2 is when this
problem becomes hard.
Now interestingly, there are
FPT algorithms with respect
to k and d.
So if k and d are small,
this problem is easy.
And for planar graphs, there's
a subexponential FPT algorithm
as well.
But when d is unbounded,
if it's not a parameter,
only k is, then this problem
is hard even for planar graphs.
So planar is w1
hard with respect
to k, only when d can be
part of the input arbitrarily
large function of n.
And also ETH implies there's
no planar algorithm with time
2-- sorry, f of k n to the
little o of square root of k.
And in fact, for
scattered set, there
is an n to the big O of
square root of k algorithm.
I don't think it's
been published,
but it's mentioned in the book.
And there is-- this is tight.
This says there is no n to the
little o of square root of k
algorithm, even when you get an
arbitrary computable function f
of k in front.
So this is nice.
We're planar, so we
lose the square aspect,
but it's actually a pretty
easy reduction from grid tiling
with less than or equal to.
So you can see the grid here,
k equals 3 in this example.
And here, n equals 5, just like
our earlier example in fact.
All the information is here, as
represented by these little red
sticks.
So we have a 3 by 3 matrix.
In each matrix cell,
we have a set of items.
In this case, there
are two items.
In this case there
are three items.
The items are encoded by
where the red sticks are
in this subgrid.
This is an n by n subgrid
within a k by k matrix.
So for every present
pair in this set sij,
we just add a stick.
Now, the stick is
a really long path.
It's 100 times n.
So we have this n by
n grid, and then we
have these hundred n paths.
Now this is still planar.
You can put that path in there.
And also, this red path is
100, and these are length 1.
Black edges are length 1.
So what's shown here is actually
satisfying assignment where
I choose one of these vertices.
In scattered set,
our goal is to choose
vertices that are very
far away from each other.
How far?
How far is 301 times n plus 1.
Roughly, three red
sticks plus one traversal
of a subgrid plus 1.
Roughly three red sticks.
So if I choose this vertex and
I want to choose one in here,
it's got to be at least
three red sticks away.
So I'm going to get one red
stick here, one red stick here,
and one red stick there.
So that's good.
But that just says
I choose exactly
one out of each of these things.
Once I choose one
of these endpoints,
I certainly can't
choose another one
because it's only
two red sticks away.
I can only choose
one per subgrid.
But then also, I want the
lesser and equal to constraint.
And that's the plus n over here.
So I have three
red sticks plus n.
That's the 1.
Because I have plus n, n is the
width, let's say, these guys.
So once I choose
this guy, I have
to be three red sticks--
1, 2, 3 red sticks away.
But I also need to be
an additional n away.
And here, I am that because
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 away.
I'm actually one
more than n away.
And there's a plus 1 over
there, so that's good.
I'm 6 away.
I need to be 6 away.
And that corresponds
to this being
in the fourth column and this
being in the fourth column.
In other words, it corresponds
to the second coordinate
of this guy being less than or
equal to the second coordinate
of this guy.
So it's exactly the grid
tiling with less than
or equal to constraint
horizontally and symmetrically,
vertically.
Because the distance between
a point here to point
here is going to be go straight
down, jump, use the red stick,
and then go teleport
left right and then
go straight down from there.
So that distance
corresponds to exactly when
all the less than or equal
to constraints are satisfied.
If and only if, so this
a reduction from grid
tiling with less than or
equal to to scattered set.
[INAUDIBLE] is w1 hard.
Now here, notice k
prime is k squared,
because we are choosing
one vertex per matrix cell.
And they're k squared cells.
So here we are losing
the quadratic blowup.
Questions?
One more similar example.
There aren't a ton
of hardness results
here, so not a lot
to choose from.
There are some multi-way
[? Kant and ?] other things.
But among simple
examples, here's
another simple example--
very similar looking.
This is a graph in 2D
plane, so to speak.
You can also think of it as
a unit disk graph problem.
So a unit disk graph is I take
some points in the plane, 2D
coordinates, let's say
given by rational values.
x and y-coordinates
are given by rationals.
And if I look at
any two vertices,
if they live-- if the
distance between them
is less than or equal to
1, then I add an edge.
So here, I might
have a graph-- this
is going to be a lot of
edges with that notion of 1.
You can have big cliques
in a unit disk graph,
but it's kind of planar-ish.
Especially if you
have distant vertices,
they're not going
to be connected.
So you have these local cliques,
but they're kind of connected
in a planar-like way.
Definition clear?
Edge if and only if
distance at most 1.
So what about independent
set in unit disk graphs?
We know independent
set in general's hard.
Independent set in unit disk
graphs is almost as hard.
Again, there's a quadratic
loss in the parameter.
But problem is, w1 hard
and has the same kind
of hardness as scattered set.
By similar kind of
structure, here I'm
actually giving
you the grid tiling
with less than or equal to.
Probably also corresponds
to the last example,
but here it is in the
independent set unit disk
problem.
Independent set in a unit
disk is the same thing
as choosing some
vertices, like this one,
as the center of
a radius one half
disk and then those
radius one half disks
should not intersect each other.
Because these two things
will have distance at least 1
if and only if radius one
half disk and a radius
one half disk here
do not intersect.
So it's really about
choosing centers
for these disks that don't hit.
And so again, what
we're going to do
is imagine an n by n subgrid
within each cell of the matrix.
But not all of those points
are actually in the set,
only the ones that
are in-- in this case,
s1,1 these pairs of guys
as written here, so 1,
1 is in there.
I guess that's that guy.
2,5 is this guy.
3,3 is that guy.
Those points we'll actually
put in the problem.
These tiny dots are
just place markers.
There's no actual point there.
Then we construct the unit
disk graph on the structure.
And again, if we
set the unit right,
and these are super tiny,
in the same way that we
had the red edges,
which were, like,
100 times longer than the
small things over here,
we're going to have, let's say
this thing is 100 times smaller
than that distance, enough
so that these circles act
kind of like squares.
If you look very close to
here, this looks straight.
So these are very
compressed, so it's probably
going to be more like
a factor of n smaller.
These effectively
act like squares.
It's just a matter of
whether the horizontal extent
of this disk hits the
horizontal extent of this disk.
And that is a less than
or equal to constraint.
Once you choose something
in column 2 here,
the next one has to
be column at least 2.
Here, there there's a gap
because we chose column 3.
Here, there's a gap
because we chose column 5.
But for example here, we
chose column 2, column 2
and these guys are
almost touching.
But barely not touching.
And as long as you have
the less than or equal to
constraint on the columns,
then you'll be OK.
The disk won't intersect
and it's an if and only if.
So again, we
represent grid tiling
with less than or equal
to and independent
set or disk packing
problem in the plane.
It's kind of cool.
Questions?
All right.
Well-- oh, more fun facts.
So we have for independent
set in unit disk graphs,
we have that there
is no f of k n
to the little o of square
root of k algorithm.
There actually is
an n to the big O
of square root of k algorithm.
We also get-- and I
won't go through this.
I think it's pretty
trivial, based
on what I said last class.
But we get that
there's no efficient p
test for this problem
unless-- sorry.
This we definitely
get from last lecture.
I said if you're w1 hard
or FPT-- if you're w1 hard
and FPT does not equal
w1, then you are not FPT.
If you're not FPT, there's
no efficient p test,
no f of 1 over epsilon
times n to some constant.
In fact, if you assume ETH,
you get an even stronger form
of that.
And in this example, we
get there is no 2 to the 1
over epsilon to the 1
minus delta power times
n to the order 1 1 plus
epsilon approximation.
This is the original result
from the Daniel Marx paper
that introduced-- this was
his motivation for introducing
grid tiling.
So again, you get-- out
of all these lower bounds,
you also get results about
inapproximability, which
is another reason to care.
Even if you don't care about
parametrized complexity,
these are the only ways known
to prove lower bounds on how
slow your p test has to be.
Because there are p
tests for these problems,
but only so efficient.
That's it for fixed
parameter tractability.
Next class, we'll do something
completely different.